le fentanyl l'on vous en parle depuis
quelques jours il continue de faire des
ravages au canada depuis cinq ans près
de 700 personnes seraient mortes après
avoir consommé ce puissant d'anti
douleurs et les sur dow semble tout à
coup se multiplient un peu partout au
pays
bonsoir frédéric jond ce livre je pense
que d'abord il faudrait rappeler un
petit peu ce que c'est justement le
fentanyl sa médicaments disait un
antidouleur oui c'est un analgésique
très très fort en fait entre 50 et 100
fois plus puissant que la morphine voilà
donc c'est très fort on prescrit souvent
saoûls personnes qui souffrent de
douleurs persistantes constante
chronique par exemple ceux qui souffrent
du cancer des os
ce que ça fait c'est que ça ça agit en
fait sur le cerveau et ça permet une
d'augmenter la tolérance à la douleur le
problème c'est qu'il ya un lien des
revendeurs de drogue sans scrupules qui
décide de transformer le fin d'année
pour en faire des produits qui
lorsqu'ils sont à gérer on vraiment des
conséquences épouvantables quand vous
allez le voir dans ce reportage
pour ray johnstone c'est une autre
journée au chevet de son fils anthony 18
ans il ya presque un mois celui ci a
consommé pour la première fois à des
fins récréatives ce qu'ils croyaient
être de l'oxycontin un puissant anti
douleur
en fait il s'agissait plutôt de fentanyl
qui a fait un arrêt respiratoire dit-il
il a failli en mourir
jusqu'il ya peu le fentanyl était
disponible au canada seulement sous
forme de timbres
ce puissant analgésique qui créent très
vite une dépendance peut être coupé
fumée ou injectée mais à partir de 2013
la police a découvert que le fentanyl en
poudre était dorénavant mélangé à de
l'héroïne et de la cocaïne pour
fabriquer des fausses pilules
d'oxycontin en entrevue avec sylvie cyr
détenus de la saskatchewan qui a revendu
plusieurs drogues dont le fentanyl
reconnaît qu'il est trop tard pour
stopper le phénomène
une drogue à la mode qui fait des
ravages chez ceux qui ne savent
probablement pas ce qu'ils consomment
le risque de surdose et donc plus grands
la police d'halifax qui a arrêté hier
pour la première fois un présumé
revendeurs de fentanyl fait tout ce
qu'elle peut pour enrayer ce dangereux
phénomène devenu pancanadien en trois
ans seulement sept cliniques a reçu la
visite de plus de mille patients
dépendants du fentanyl ce médecin pense
que seulement 5 % d'entre eux s'en
sortiront tous les parents devraient
s'inquiéter dit il le fentanyl est
maintenant partout ray johnstone c'est
que son fils aura des séquelles
permanentes mais il reste quand même
optimiste il ne sais pas jusqu'à quel
point tu n'y retrouvera six facultés
ouais frédéric malheureusement on a le
sentiment qu'on parle de plus en plus de
sainte anne est la cause de tous ces
décès à travers le pays qu'on lui
attribue oui c'est dur en fait si on
regarde les chiffres entre 2009 et 2014
il y a eu au canada 655 des sécurités
attribua le directement la consommation
de fatal il seulement l'ontario 466 et
quand on regarde les chiffres maintenant
pour les décès qui ont été constatés
pour lesquelles on a trouvé des traces
de fats aligne dans l'organisme de ces
gens-là ça monte à 1019 un chiffre pour
le québec
sur les cinq dernières années en fait on
a constaté 46 décès directement
attribuables aux fentanyl et pour vous
montrer un petit peu à quel point c'est
quasiment exponentielle cette croissance
est tendance et que en ontario on avait
en 2009 63 décès et ça presque doublé en
2013 donc ça continue de grandir et
s'inquiètent beaucoup évidemment les
autorités de santé publique et aussi les
services policiers qui ne savent pas
trop où donner de la tête pour essayer
de d'arrêter là cette croissance
phénomène de vente de fentanyl encore
seulement clandestins c'est très
clandestins et c'est ça aussi qui est
très dangereux parce qu'on ne sait pas
comment il est fabriqué en fait ce
produit là et ce soir encore à toronto
il ya eu un vol en fait de deux fameux
timbre la de fentanyl et on a
l'impression qu'une fois de plus ça va
se retrouver dans la rue sous des formes
diverses avec malheureusement
probablement des décès possibles à la
clé terrible merci beaucoup frêle années
qu'ils sourient